the Humboldt squid is one of nature's
most impressive predators it has three
hearts keen eyesight a large brain two
lightning-fast tentacles eight grasping
arms and a razor-sharp beak
dr. Bob Gilly a neurobiologist at
Hopkins marine station in Pacific Grove
California as studied squid for more
than two decades on this mission he's
headed for the Gulf of California to
hook up with Bob Cranston the cameraman
who has logged more time at depth with
the Jumbo squid than anyone on earth let
me take this from you because Gilly does
not dive himself Bob will serve as his
eyes underwater so he can get a close
look at the Red Devils in their own
element the team heads to an area where
squid have been seen before they'll wait
till dusk when it is believed that the
Red Devils rise from as far down as 2300
feet to a barely accessible 200 feet
like many deep dwelling creatures
Humboldt squid are not very sensitive to
red light the first part of the spectrum
to disappear in the ocean lights so Bob
will be using red lights and red
equipment in the hopes that he'll be
less intrusive to the squid allowing him
to get more natural behavior up close
red is camouflage underwater so we're
we're trying to add some red but still
have something we can film with
the first squid to swim into view seemed
to take no notice of the light
so perhaps Bob and gillies theory that
the squid are less able to process red
light is correct
a squid approaches Bob can see it but is
it seeing him
apparently it is but at first it seems
more curious than aggressive then a
bolder squid attacks the camera
now the devil seemed to be coming from
all directions
one attacks the lights then they turn
their attention to Bob himself and his
worst nightmare materializes as one
squid nearly Yanks off his mask
then as quickly as it all began it's
over
congratulations Bob now Bob gets to show
off his footage to Gilly you know
they're coming in at full speed ahead
yeah grab the prey and full speed really
the ink movie the red light was a
success even though the squid could see
it they approached much closer than in
white light and Bob has gotten superb
images in return it makes you suspect
that they have incredible intelligence
to see this exploration type behavior
and I I certainly believe they have a
lot of intelligence